where are my balloons didi when I say
Falcon fury that's supposed to cue the
balloons welcome to your weekly ticket
staying safe at home edition I really
wanted to try and bring her on again
this is not going we start off with the
news that Sony Pictures has just
announced the delay of spider-man 3 and
spider-man into the spider verse part to
do two kovin 19 spider-man 3 was
scheduled to premiere on July 16 2021
that date has now been moved to November
5th 2021 meanwhile the sequel to
spider-man into the spider verse was
originally slated to debut on April 8
2022 and it will now hit theaters on
October 7 2022 and to make room for that
shift Doctor Strange into the multiverse
of madness the second solo doctor
strange adventure has been moved from
November 2021 to March 25th 2022
but not all studios are pushing their
release dates Warner Brothers will
forego plans to release their animated
film Scoob in theaters and instead
released the film on VOD on May 15 Scoob
becomes the second major animated family
film following trolls world tour to
favor a digital debut over a theatrical
release and Olivia Wilde's newest film
don't worry darling we'll have an a-list
cast including Florence Pugh Shia
LaBeouf and Chris Pine wild will of
course direct the film which is
described as a psychological thriller
set in an isolated utopian community in
the 1950s California desert hold on
they're vacuuming the apartment hallway
and if you're looking for a great way to
kick off the weekend
check out Lionsgate live a night at the
movies
Lionsgate is partnered with fandango's
movieclips to livestream lala land for
free this weekend at 6 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time on the movieclips YouTube
channel
so grab some popcorn a comfy seat and
sit back and enjoy the show
but as always we have some personal
recommendations for you and I have a
very special guest I've been looking
forward to having on the show editor at
Rotten Tomatoes
Jacqueline Kohli Jacqueline so good to
have you what do you got oh thanks for
having me tale well I think unlike a lot
of people and I'm just dreaming of what
I'm gonna do when this is all over and
right now I'm dreaming of getting
dressed up and going out with my
girlfriends have a girls night out
so right now I'm having a girls night in
with Pride and Prejudice I just love
watching this movie you get to watch
Matthew McFadden and Keira Knightley
fall in love and Regency England and I
think right now is we're all maybe
trying to date in the time of quarantine
it's nice and refreshing to watch a time
period where people thought that holding
someone's hand was the most erotic thing
you could possibly do because I think
right now a lot of us are feeling
exactly the same about human contact but
that's me dreaming about the other side
with Keira Knightley playing Lisbeth
Bennett what about you do you have a T
recommendation to drink while watching
that I mean Earl Grey would be like
really fancy you can do something long
but yeah I'm dating that's its own show
for my film mine's more of a dare I dare
you to watch mid-summer like it's an 824
film it's about a group of young adults
that go to Sweden for a celebration
called midsummer and things get really
messed up like really messed up it is
quite an experience you'll be filled
with anxiety if you aren't already on
the poster for the movie is exactly how
I felt watching the movie it truly is
great if there's some great
cinematography it's a fantastic it's a
fantastic experience really messed up
that's my recommendation I dare you
thank you so much Jacqueline thank you
for joining me thank you for having me
tale and one day we'll unpack what it
means that you're watching midsummer
right now but that's for another day and
now available to watch in your own home
the photograph my man I wish I have put
as much courage into love as I'll put in
my work I don't want to lose you
because I'm afraid to love you when
famous photographer Christina Ames dies
unexpectedly she leaves her estranged
daughter may hurt angry and full of
questions when may finds a photograph
tucked away in a safe-deposit box she
soon finds herself delving into her
mother's early life an investigation
that leads to an unexpected romance with
a rising journalist the film is directed
by Stella Meggie and stars Issa Rae
laquet Stanfield chelsea peretti and
Courtney B Vance but if you're in the
mood for an action movie why not check
out Mortal Kombat legends scorpions or
revenge
I Shang Tsung welcome you to Mortal
Kombat the protector of earth realm Lord
Raiden must assemble his realms greatest
fighters to defend it against the aging
Shang Tsung who is looking for another
realm to crush Kevin Michael Richardson
reprised his role as Goro since voicing
the character in the 1995 Mortal Kombat
the film is also fresh with a 100% on
the tomato meter well that's it for this
week let us know in the comments if
you'll be seeing the photograph or
Mortal Kombat legends scorpions revenge
I'm Cal not amiss and I'll see you next
week it's so nice to be outside again
I didn't think I'm getting a little bit
of Sun that are put on some sunscreen
[Music]